[Music]
all guys welcome to today's lecture
promises choice in today's lecture I am
going to discuss few games between left
pegasi and Viktor Korchnoi from kindest
man in nineteen nineteen eighty which
coercion eventually won and eventually
when playing against Antalya Karpov the
virtual machine match it was semi final
this one then after this one he
qualified to play against Huebner and he
beat Hitler as well and then play Karpov
however in this dispatch specifically
was very interesting it was very close
and the lots of interesting and fighting
games were going on apartment there was
lots of drama around this this match
going on but this is different different
story completely however just just wise
it was I mean two fighters right and
both going for further winces with
number one with both colors so and here
in they had a very interesting duel in
Queens Indian defense and I will start
the show in the first game the second
game and then finally the third one did
they played a specific line and talk at
night I'm talking about either side now
the free life six it can happen or 70
for the D for short Castle this is also
modern theory is quite intensive here as
well basically they're free popular
moves here is the Knight c3 which is
I've been mostly played rook e1 is also
very common and finally the most
interesting one however also risky is d5
and at the time it was pretty much
nearly an innovation
not very innovation but basically it
takes d5 it was quite rare that that's
for sure and the mode that has been
always played here was move Knight to d4
and this will happen in their first
first game did happen in this this match
and I'm pretty sure I'm that corner was
a little bit surprised with this move I
don't know but from the reaction that he
chose in the first game that they played
it was pretty outside imprecise because
here he played number of knight c6 and
this is the first game we were talking
about the day that they play in this
line
she takes d5 Knight takes d4 Queen takes
d4 and in this position basically all
them according to even more fury the
most popular move right now is c5 is by
far the most popular move however it
leads to I've in my opinion at least
better position for white because of the
pawn structure and this Bishop on me 7
is kind of misplaced she would be I mean
that it's not so easy to develop it and
it would be better on the other diagonal
let's say on d7 frames were supported is
b5 and right now the Queen can simply
come back in d6 a for this what happened
in this match in this game and was
causing a moment
why was 30 bar and eventually pugazh
gonna win in the game
however in this position there is
additional possibility which is Bishop
to c5 and at the time I mean no one
played it obviously and so far according
to the why will I check it every other
database it will only one playing one
game mean played it like that
and I try to find something for right
and maybe White has some small edge but
objectively block is doing quite well
for instance
Queen Queen of queef queen d3 a 593
rocky 8
and the idea of Bishop a6 maybe
improving this bishop and maybe playing
sometimes 94/95 could be possible
depending of course what on what white
is doing also Queen e7 maybe D 697
sometimes maybe I was playing through
scissors there there is a number of
possible scenarios of what can happen
and what kind of depending on what kind
of plan black choose and worldwide does
in general it feels to me that position
should be around equal but definitely
position is playable so this was the
best thing was the course I could do
however he played moves c5 and this is
good after Queen d3 we transfer and d6 I
say a for this position is similar to
benoni because of the white point d5 and
black pawns d65
and however there is big there is some
it is somewhat different because
normally man only pawns Bishop is
already on g7 here Bishop is on e7 right
so it is towards advantage the bishop is
only 7 because only 7 is not so active
on this diagonal is perfectly offered
you know those of practical
possibilities however only 7 is to be
still improved
let's save 97 we should have 6 for
instance so like is to spend some time
to improve this [ __ ] anyway I may not
be easy because if white plays Bishop a4
pawn disease would be pretty much always
under let's say attack of this Bishop on
f4 so in this position caution played a
6 and right now possibly the best move
old Bishop f4
kind of like my thinking trying to
decide where design where this night
goes from b1 this ion later let's maybe
Knight d2 maybe Nancy from Vanessa a3
and we should never very luckily is the
best place for this Bishop and but
instead a progress keeping with Knight
f3 which is also a move I like because 9
heads to c4 at some point obviously
however you know it's looks a little bit
strange to me and this outplayed
probably before after only 3 b5 happened
and this is sort of the problem that a
free
not really a problem but like a little
you know if you play be sure the forest
wouldn't be I mean this would unlikely
would be a problem right now because
then we can even we can take it we can
easily our Knight d2 where it's better
place than a three so I don't know but
possibly it doesn't really matter just
kind of like what I was thinking in
which I before happened before not sure
whether this is correct also be take say
for was pretty much possible or maybe
some other move like Queen b6 because or
maybe c4 even c4c were also possible
because I don't like I well I don't like
about before is that the weekends c4 c4
square and actually White Knight went to
a free just went to c4 so they're sort
of helps white but you know it's
therefore I would consider something
else but question is from grandmas or a
scorching for sure had his reasons why
he played before here a 5 e for Bishop
a6
Queen c2 and we got to let's say typical
position for bonanni again with the
difference between seven which is
definitely in White's favor also die
just already on c4 which causes the
entire Queen side to be sort of blocked
and in general it feels like White has
good chances here to end this and this
is why actually I want to make a point
here
very often when we play when players are
surprised they choose sub-optimal lines
or paths and eventually you know
eventually person who managed to
surprise Oakland has some can get some
edge organs can hope for some eyes
that's why probably operating
preparation is a lot about surprising
our opponent and creating practical
problems because I'm pretty sure in this
position
not sure I'm pretty sure that the five
move caution analyzed but I'm pretty
pretty sure that here in this position
all of this was maybe he knew this but
he wasn't entirely sure and more he
didn't remember so it already gives some
room for error for our opponent so after
23 d 6 a 4 a 3 that 93 all those moves
here while is simply study better so
caution is how to eliminate this problem
of this night immediately because
probably after 97 instead there could be
some issues with move like maybe Bishop
takes d6 and sacrifice an exchange and
for the two pawns even but even if not
that there could be move which I'm gonna
talk about in a moment which is e 5 for
instance after this this night didn't
happen in the game same idea but and
right now is the critical position and I
think progress he made a mistake right
now because he move rook F d1 and
instead I believed it was time to play
move e5 everything is pretty much ready
and if we don't do this right now
as white black will be able to improve
the bishop improve the night kick our
queen out of c4 and most importantly
removed the ruko from a 8 somehow or may
release prevent if I from happening
because that there is tactical idea
involving this if I move that if the
taxi 5 we go d6 for instance if let's
save Knight takes d5 Bishop takes d6 and
block well this is just winning for for
white therefore I believe that in this
position after E 5 better move would be
the sadita as if I but it also doesn't
solve problems
d6 we shall take the six beautiful x8 it
takes a four here there is also
additional piece for blog which is the
night
it creates some let's say practical
problems but as I analyzed after Luke
fd1 white is simply doing very well and
for instance example I'm queen of six we
should be seven just protein the Bishop
Knight b6 Queen b5 in the pond on a five
is nine iron b6 we shall be five takes
Bishop takes B 2 or B 1 B shop d4 and
this position it's very important to
take on the four eliminate this Bishop
because after a g3 otherwise would be
pretty dangerous
however we eliminate this Bishop Queen
and queen cannot type because Queen
takes be 6 if context we go Quinn text
before and we have passed a pawn which
will support of the bishop on the light
squares Bishop of b7 will very likely
promote to the to the queen of course
it's still long game like Bach has some
defensive resources but definitely white
is in charge here so this would be
better but still after if five losses of
all the problems finally I came up with
this conclusion that the best move for
black here would be g5 and this move is
I think pretty much extraordinary it
weakens the King right and after it
takes the six individuals you know what
is just winning but we just play calm
move Bishop f6 and finally this Bishop
got to this long diagonal this one comes
to d4 maybe at some point and pawn on d6
will likely fall as we will see in a
moment
very suspicious ones the best move
Bishop to d4 which was running over
active ideas Knight e5 and so on are all
there and this weakened as weakness of
the black king is not really a problem
for now what we should as why we should
try to make it a problem so in this
position I believe that a move like we
need to be interesting the idea is first
of all to get out of this 95 10 P and if
not have seen we have Bishop to g5 so
for black it makes sense to playing with
h6 trying to prevent this
cover this G 5.56 next 8 for King g7
analyze and of course very speculative
what can happen here but I believe in
general the black should have black
should be you know doing quite okay even
though why this definitely bar for
instance we should be free takes takes
still is this extra pawn and after Queen
d2 let's say Lukasik seems like was only
move because Queen f6 Bishop h3 could be
very annoying regressive intake with the
rook on d6 and first analyze this this
this and right now we've looked for I
feel like white has some pressure but if
the perfect play black should be able to
eventually hold it this was the best
what could have happened with perfect
day for both on both sides in my opinion
so but definitely if I was the best in
this position if I was the best try to
play for a win because after let's see
what happens roughly the program d1
program d1 simply preparing if I've but
you know back in 80s maybe it wasn't if
it wasn't still a thing such dynamic
let's say approach modern chess right
now is that basically everything so
concrete that you know we just have to
calculate a lot you know you don't have
time to play move like you know row gave
you asked to improve the position slow
you just have to go immediately and go
for the initiative and already back then
it was beginning to be like this
especially in 80s as part of became
world champion and so on and nineties
and so on also earlier Fischer it
already started the process but maybe it
wasn't like so prominent yet but you
know since 80s since let's say Karpov
Kasparov matches and so on was all about
initiative dynamics and so on maybe this
is at this transitional period it was
basically more like dogmatic and so on
and pragmatic but right now modern chess
is all about basically intuitive and
concrete calculations so on so therefore
I would I think that if I was basically
the best move ruger fd1 happened the
game and let's see what happens could
not be six Queen b5 and right now
Queen c7 played correctly which is a big
mistake it's a serious mistake right now
after this move why this just back in
back back in charge best move was Bishop
f6 Bishop f6 with the idea is here to
simply put pressure on b2 and stop e5
there is and there is I know
suddenly I believe that black is just
doing great
simply light is just doing great right
now and I'm not sure whether White has
here any any advantage for instance the
problem is after E 5 right now again g5
maybe is the only move obviously but it
simply works you know it's all about
calculation and you know where something
works doesn't work or doesn't work here
it simply works so takes takes for
instance and it seems like it's one of
six very dangerous right because black
kind of take on f6 because point xB six
but on the other hand there is no way to
make good use of it for instance if
black goes 97 policies would be will
simply fall so if g4 we can just play
Ruby 8 I was thinking FG 5 just 27 and
basically try if we trade the Queen's
that comes to e5 also these ideas of h6
always black could be simply better here
so I am not entirely convinced whether
here or a after Bishop f6 what has any
advantage maybe it's just better a
little bit better for black it would be
my very careful let's say suggests kind
of like not solution like I know how to
put it can think I would just think that
black pushing maybe not bear is no bit
easier to play e5 g5 is work and does
work so in this position after Queen c7
this was a big mistake and again right
now if I've simply works you just have
dynamically it just works however
progress he didn't do it again
rogue ascribe Bishop h3 for instance
after if I've again this problem of
rügen 8a remains and if black many black
white man just like
exposition be strategically it was
nearly winning forward therefore I mean
this is just really bad because broken a
little gonna hate Falls this is just
pretty much game over
so if I was again much stronger move but
be sure it free is very prophylactic or
move prevents 97 rogue FBA happened and
trying to kind of play it 1985 but after
Kweisi six Queen d8 position finally
right now progress could play d5 and
place basically backsplash and collapses
in order not to kind of be talked about
this game too much because we have three
games to cover today in the new on this
topic I just want to show the game and
see the critical a critical moment what
what could have happened here
so night c4 he takes the six Bishop
takes d6 we should take the six Knight
takes the six Queen texif are basically
with all those only moves basic because
all rooms are although all the moves are
pretty much only if 3065 d6 and or
billion sorry big special extra and then
t6 is just crushing there is no way to
to do anything here with black so
basically only at only transfer black
would be tried to hold on on d6 square
but after simply this while we is the
pawn be free
trying to get before square further so
good practical attempt but after Ruby
for Ruby seven is important to this this
Bishop is on h3 because cover c8 Square
always so Roxy was impossible
Ruby 7 had to be played rooks one h6
Quincy three Ruby 823 what is simply
much better why has huge advantage it's
just extra pawn and black doesn't have
enough compensation
Titan DC is a good defensive piece but
it doesn't by enemies offer enough
Condor compensation for the lack of the
of the phone so in the game having to be
seven and there are now javaScript
Athena for possibly was already time
trouble are
because it was moving I moved number 31
and as we know in those times there was
this time control without the increment
so very likely he was already around
here in time trouble and right now I
think that Queen d2 was in this position
it's of Queen a4 was just the simplest
one conferring all the Condor play and
no Roxy six for instance or ox five or
six five or six is coming next move with
simply winning positioning I suppose was
possible to improve this Bishop say to F
3 square
kingi to slowly improve the position is
simply crushing but progress Cupid Queen
a4 and suddenly after rookie two things
are not entirely clear because Roxy
Sigma had to be his idea but after
simple Ruby 6 what to do next and right
now I believe progress had one only move
that was winning only one and this move
okay hit everybody once the position but
and this move right now was rogue d1 and
it is a logical move however he didn't
do it because also it seemingly makes
sense to play moving roadog d2 and this
is what he did Rudy took he played in
the groove an idea of trading pieces and
covering b2 pond and you know if rook e1
the scissors just one track you know and
presumably it always however this
creates sort of tension on this Queen
and Queen and rogue right like the Queen
has if we can impact a key the Queen out
of a for Rubin it will fall and possibly
was I mean was when I'm 35 both players
were for sure in time travel with my
assumption but in this position actually
course I would had chance to save the
game will get at the moment but I just
want to show why in this position
Ruby one was by far the best move after
Ruby one let's say if route iced be 224
wins the game on the spot because both
workers are hanging or Texas d66 game
over
and if g5 again just quindi for the
ideas that Queen comes to the fore and
this is simply it wide wins covers all
the frets covers all the weaknesses
phase of the our opponent and covers all
the weaknesses and there is nothing
black can do simply wins in the game
happened here Ruby Dee - and suddenly
was peers are not so well placed and
right now after g5 this the game ended
quite quickly because after 24 it right
now is the same thing Queen is securely
the secure now I'll have before and
supports the rook on d2 well and after
loop before Quincy free white simply
wins for instance rook e1 bishop f1
rogue a for rookie to only move but good
enough and is enough to win training the
best and the most active rook routed up
with Daisy to Queen d7 Bishop d3 and the
game ended let's just see how it ended
because this is simply all completely
crushing the wide ruby sauce was just
much more active and she's just very as
pass it's a good piece by the very
passive piece and black king is also in
big danger right now as well so this is
simply winning also after Queen five
what has winning attack right now so
this is how the game ended this position
poganski sorry cautionary resigned so in
this position coming back a little bit
to the move to 35 in this position
instead of g5 there was move before
Andrew before basically saved and I
saved the day for for Kirchner group d6
rook e1 track kingi a king g2 and queen
of a suddenly this Queen cannot defend
the robe on d6 you couldn't defend let's
say Aldrovandi - at first but right now
can't defend rook on d6 like it's pretty
unique but like in this position simply
like white black mr. Lubin d6 unless
what tries to quintics before but Queen
takes before it was a queen sacrifice
which
complicated position complicates the
position a lot of through six Queen
seven who knows what's going on black
and easily also take over if what makes
some mistakes all friends eternal
especially for a little bit rocky one
when you want Kim Quint XD two and point
B two falls upon these pond opponents
sort of also stopped likely of course
position is positive community and clear
I believe that with best played against
England draw and for instance the six f5
analyze you can take because twenty five
which will be free just King gauge seven
seonbae two is hanging all the time
possibly it just draw somehow but you
know it would have had come the game we
just turn around completely from and as
basically in this position after roopd
one this is simply winning for a couple
gave scheme right
so this is the first game I want to talk
about and this is how basically after
this g5 move here g5 through twenty four
and so on this is how progress q1 and so
on so in next in the same a game we see
in the next game I mean between Korchnoi
and Palgrave ski the same line happened
basically I believe that the progress
keep Pogue asked his team and his
seconds came up to the conclusion that
this is a very good line
so after 94 in this position they
repeated but coronary curve and his team
very likely preferred an improvement and
the improvement of the bishops e6 the
and this this is pretty much in style of
course not because move Bishop c6 just
tries to hold on to an extra pound that
was sacrificed and tries to prove that
there is no knowledge of compensation
for for white and coercion I loved
grabbing pawns so this is very
interesting and legit line and even
lately by some reason this move
been quite popular but I believe that it
offers quite quite good chances for
black
however it's of course also a little bit
risky but if you want to play for a win
and was placed definitely worth playing
for in front from number one first of
all white sacrifices the pawn here and
right after this b6 coroner accepts the
spot and tries to hold on to it and
prove the he's right about this extra
pawn so it just shows what kind of
mental approach they had to the game how
aggressive they were and how they wanted
to to win basically so after right now
bishops ECB is very interesting move
because ideas be Knight takes c6 d takes
c6 I called into this point if I was a
65 65
let's see free c6 dozen extra pawn right
of course white has compensation here
let's say e for and for instance if
detects if for Knight takes e4 Knight XE
for Bishop takes e4 for instance I
believe that bla white would have had a
pretty good conversation because night
and rook are not easily developed right
now however in this position I believe
that if we call 96 immediately
blacks position is pretty good the thing
is that if we take here which takes f6
Bishop takes c6 we could black and trade
Queens Quinta is e1 rook takes D 1 rook
88 for instance in this position
actually this white bishop on C one that
has andrew.galea one that have issues
the developing forward like you know
from very initial squares right now
Bishop f6 is very active night joins the
game very quickly and the fact that
white has pair of bishops is not so
important because this was Bishop on c1
zone is develop this position was
already Bishop on e3 pawn on be free
traded drugs
of course what is better but dynamically
here black is doing very well
so this school have been a idea by
y-coordinate
so here progress key also accepted sort
of the challenge and tries to win the
center by playing seed 85 which overlays
d5 Bishop takes d5 Knight takes d5 and E
for alternative would have been 95 I I
was thinking after 96 for instance I
feel like bug is doing well because
neither c3 Knight c6 Bishop g5 it's also
seemingly all natural moves but after
very solid 98 I don't see any problems
here for for for black for instance
after 97 97 95 f6 and if Knight x e7
queen takes a certain acquitting 7
losses we need 7 losses obviously
because 25 but very important move King
h8 and right now both bishop and the and
Knight are hanging and as white count
different both so very lucky this is the
best move and after 95 let's say c6
positions around equal for instance 9
types of 16 types of 6 positions just
around equal and there is no reason why
that would be worth or what would be
better so equal material very lucky next
move d5 if Queenston couldn't be to
Queen Sakuni two of apples are being
traded three magic proposition so if if
or here this would happen in the game
night before Knight c3 and we are not
gonna cover by the way entire game
because the game was nearly 100 moves
but we'll discuss unto up to a point
where it was clear that canary had good
chances to win the game because he won
this game so Knight c3 and Knight of
Bishop f6 Knight a5 and right now rook
e8 and this is the critical position I
believe because I've it feels to me
personally that white still has some
compensation white still has some
compensation it's not like that this is
just extra pawn and for black and white
has no conversation definitely what has
some compensation but the thing is that
with initiative you have to be very
accurate and precise of what we are
doing if you
go kind of if you make a mistake once or
twice certainly the entire initiative
can evaporate you will just find
yourself with in a position palm down
and this is one of those examples and
this is sort of very often what coronary
was taught me to do it so it's grad upon
proof that he was right about keeping
proving no compensation and just win the
game like that so in the game happened
f4 but in my opinion the best move here
was a three and the idea is that we want
to chase this night away from before
mostly Muslim and because none before
does even though it's a little bit
artificial
let's do quite much there it does really
really one important function which is
covering the v square and it's very
important for what is to actually place
our night on t on d5 for instance after
96-95 would be very unpleasant for for
black for instance or tasty for queen
ruby one for instance g6 Queen f3 rookie
six before analyzed and all white pieces
are perfectly placed and even though
black it's two points two pawns up both
pieces on the Queen side especially with
a connection Dino c6 they are not really
doing much and they're actually object
of the attack let's see before maybe
coming some D's on this diagonal also
some problems and if six could be
possible at some point definitely white
is just much better however bishops III
would be better move trying to simplify
the position and eliminate this night on
however again this Bishop has black
Bishop takes c3 this weakens the king
and suddenly raise Bishop h6 possible so
it's also not entirely trivial what's
going on if let's say of course if gtex
h6 queen g4 is very very strong Quincy
596 just means the Queen
otherwise just made so g6 93 and again
rotate Z 495 again I've comes to d5
Queen f3 is coming and again I believe
that white has very strong conversation
for for this pawn so this was what I
believe progress key had to do even this
line basically is very greedy and
critical will currently played try to
grab this pawn and prove he is right
however it is very dangerous and I think
that progress q best play after a three
he had chances to get really good good
game and eventually maybe we even win
the game however he played of four and
the four is of course also interesting
by just play a five however after d6
you know if the only five of if I was
neutralized after Queen g4 there is no
really any threat and after night c6
you know positions with basically I know
like if white doesn't do anything
quickly and I'll see what I can do you
know anything quickly but that position
would simply be good for black and again
happily 5d takes d5 94 it takes a
four-night h6 trying to some by the way
if I've 94-94 his typical idea should
say that of sacrificing a pawn and
improving and bringing 1x one more piece
to the to the center and to the attack
however tactically it seems like
everything worked from back
it takes a 406 King a fight there was
only one track that takes f6
Queen takes of thing and we can't forget
the Black has already three extra pounds
so after the rock Taizo for rookie Juan
kingi 295 position extremely tactical
but you I believe that our culture has
an upper upper hand eventually after all
those complications
we got to the endgame where black is
simply better there is equal material
true but the pin on the first rank is
very annoying and black has very good
chances to win this game so just just so
few moves kinky to the pin is just very
frustrating so he disciple guys decide
to get out of this pin by doing the King
but it leaves the page to pond
unattended so here eventually coaching
managed to win a pawn and after long
game because the game lost 95 moves
eventually correctly went on winning
this game but from a theoretical point
of view it was very interesting approach
by Korchnoi
and very typical for question just grab
the pawn and try to prove that he's
right about you know being having this
extra pawn so this lead is I don't know
exactly what was the score of the of the
match at this point but I know for sure
that in general progress he didn't have
many problems in the openings with black
pieces but you know they eventually he
was he lost the match it was very pretty
tight match but like in general with he
was he was doing with will he never had
any problems with black but he with why
he managed to lose some games but also
he didn't know that he didn't lose any
games but like you know in general he
didn't have much problems this this
discussion this opening was very
interesting in versus my opinion so in
this position finally in the next match
in next game this would be game number
12 I believe of the match in this
position pokrovsky came up with a
completely new idea it wasn't as I
checked at least in the database it
wasn't really a novelty but it was very
rare move and maybe according to back
then knowledge and so on it was a
novelty because you know the
access to the information was pretty
much a symmetrical so he came up his
team with the move knowledge for and
this is actually the most popular move
nowadays so as you can see basically
that's how the theory and so and you
know develops first there are several
tries to move here 94 but and there are
some games and finally black is
seemingly to do quite well there's
because there is some revenue has been
found but suddenly the completely
unexplored line suddenly pops up and
there is night age for being played and
back in the day they like when this game
was played we was like going to be few
games there you know play played on and
suddenly this became the most potable
line in this line with more than
thousand games played over the last four
years so this is just how the theory
develops now it for happened and the the
what was the point the the thing is that
right now we actually friend tag on d5
and that anyway goes to five but we
actually went to take on the far as well
so c6 makes sense.you takes it takes d5
Knight takes d5 and 95 and after 95
pretty much black has some choice but in
general because as the main move the
best one is considered to be move 97 97
is the by far the most popular move and
the modern fury focuses on this move if
45 93 bishop of six fights also not a
six is possible but I really like I
think this verse is a little bit more
accurate it is the most popular one this
is the molar theory of the real Knight
f6 but there are less popular and in
general is considered white is doing
well there
however in this position course I was
for sure surprised especially it will be
so little gains for likely he was pretty
much a novelty novel idea at least and
canary made immediately a big mistake
he played move Bishop to c5 Bishop c5
and this is a big mistake because are in
the right now blood can play E for let's
say a 97 if 9 f6 here white can play
simply 598 and if 95 against similarly
as we discussed earlier in the previous
game Bishop h6 if g h6 quincy for this
typical tactical motive here three six
we should take the fight this is simply
winning 4y decide 96 rook e1 might see
free I mean exchange up 40 pounds true
but you know very likely most pawns are
going to be doubled also all the dark
squares around black King are weak
basically it's very very bad position
for for black so 95 doesn't work and
night yet ver very passive so I can
block playing at c3 and Bishop CA trying
to play d5 but we can just play 96 even
also the queen g4 Queen each five of
them are leading to great position for
wide and six want the simplest ones
because just put the after trades on d6
pawn only thing would be restricting box
for the development of pieces and why
this drink just great
so might've six is not not so great also
it makes sense
seven this is what corpse my plate and
of course if nice would be traded let's
say also if 96 for instance there could
be maybe takes sorry it takes and maybe
night see it trying to keep this Queen
away play d5 trying to let's say hold on
to somehow like that however there is
one small detail that possibly coronary
missed and this detail is 90 x g7 this
deal and this is right now but what is
just much better wise just crushing
simply after qg7 before does the entire
point after visualize before Queen d4 f6
Quint X before and yes what is pawn down
like this pack has extra pawn but in
this position it is way different than
in the previous one where question was
had extra pawn because right now black
king is simply very exposed while his
pair of bishops and potential of a Cove
kind of like creating an attack on black
King and also just maybe some action in
the center is just simply overwhelming
for black in my opinion for instance of
35 Queen d2 this will happen the game
might be c6 little bit too simple ties
develop in the bishop and preparing
group d1 maybe Knight c3 maybe that
every night see for lots of ideas here
for white this is simply very this is
just much better position for white
Bishop 86 happened
Ruby 195 this makes sense because it
attempts to play at c4 and trying to
even by giving away this d7 tone may
summarize black tries to simplify the
position and eliminate this Bishop on b2
but right now what can play simply night
a 393 and design if Knight c4 okay we're
going to try it 94 Bishop tech see 4.87
at least Quint external of course
there's move like if I've lots of moves
and simply win for white so course not a
knight c6 queenie free very good move
idea maybe
group double the roofs on d file for
instance also a 4 e 5 could be an idea
queen 7 and right now finally called
pokrovsky played f 494 night x d4 Bishop
takes e4 and e5 and I believe that this
is simply overwhelming position already
this is simply winning because right now
after F takes e5 black and why I can
take and I'm pretty sure that this is
what progress key have seen already way
lady 5 but right now white is simply
winning with the beautiful tactical blow
which is property 7 and this is simply
crushing simply quit date c7 quinten's
e5 and simply there is nothing white
black can do simply nearly made it's not
a mate but nearly made what has what
gets huge material advantage working as
Queen f6 King g8 Queen g5 rook e1 and I
admire the fret of Queen c7 mateys is
there
Quincy's also is a big threat it was a
if I also yeah also is a big threat
so basically Cora had to give the keep
up the Queen after this this takes takes
Bishop f6 actually problems are not
resolved yet the threat of Queen son of
mate is still there
after Bishop f7 Bishop g5 the Queen
comes through f5 right now and Friday
for the first Queen e5 Queen seven so
here to walk in seven and after Bishop
h6 postponed those pieces simply are not
holding together
it's basically Bishop we'll take a look
at some point because there is no way
this construction hold after c4 Queen h7
c5 takes takes progress is simply
winning here of the Queen g7 just maybe
so few moves
g4 pawns are simply going forward and
even though his technique was not the
best a game by some reason lasted 73
moves I don't think that he animo meant
spall his advantage even though he he
could have probably want much faster but
you know this is already kind of like
that's important the most important is
kind of the theoretical part and how how
how this how there was two great
grandmasters were bonding in the opening
phase and how they were trying to one
trick another in
you know the same opening basically
because they were you know playing back
and forth many games so let's just come
back there
d5 it takes d5 not h4 so what was kind
of the most important thing about this
and I believe in map of course this my
opinion only but the big thing about
nine h4 and in general this type of
ideas is the surprise effect for the
opponent if you can if any player can
surprise surprise opened with any line
which is analyzed and we can let's say
is let's say sound strategically sound
it sometimes even not surgical song also
this makes sometimes sense but
especially when the idea strategically
sounds new and can create some practical
problems for opponent it it very often
makes sense to use it because even
though it may be off objectively doesn't
give them may not give any advantage in
practical terms it may be very hard to
face and let's so as we have seen if
coronary one of the best players ever
right
95 new position at the 1980 right now
everyone knows 975 is the way to go but
he when at the well he will face at the
board is completely new position never
seen sterilized before so it so he made
many many mistakes on c5 before 97 97 so
after this this position is simply
really bad so out of the opening with
number 15 progress key with one eye with
one idea I'm pretty sure that he
analyzed of course also this lines with
here 97 and d5 I'm pretty certain that
he analyzed this however you know we may
not even get a chance to actually play
what we really planned because our upon
can make a mistake much earlier and we
will be able to capitalize on this
immunity and this would happen exactly
in this game 97 97 before
I was one of my favorite favorite games
to be honest and this idea of like title
seven before is one also won one of my
favorites so I don't remember when I saw
this game first time but like it made a
huge impression on me that's why I
always were I'm very happy to show it
today in today's lecture so yeah after
this Queen d2 night six basically course
I never had any chance to equalize and
progress q11 a great game so just
quickly coming back to the previous line
Knight d4 right in this position ID for
the previous game previous games it's
very often happens that you know there
is some theoretical line and there is
some you know line theory called fight
going on and but suddenly black starts
to figure you know let's say after let's
say these days this Bishop c5 is being
found and suddenly the line is being
stopped to play because black is doing
well right for instance it could be this
right now an example obviously but or
maybe this Bishop c6 bishops is also
like no seemingly no in problems
corrosion won a great game and see me
nope no problems for for black so it's
very common to step back and think what
can I do else and basically it is how
ideas are born not h4 se means basically
it applies to any opening the line goes
on and on and general conclusion is that
the line is positions equal suddenly we
step to three moves back we come come a
community new thing and position just
it's completely new full of life and
this just shows how rich came chess is
and the unlimited potential of chess
so I sit since I truly believe that
chess has even though such the rapid
of computers and especially lately LC 0
and so on and off a zero and so on
I believe that chess as the game has
still lots of potential and please which
is pretty much unlimited unlimited
involves games even there was ninety
eighty nineteen eighty involves games
simply confirmed that that's pretty much
all I have for today about the progress
key and course my ball in Queens and
queens Indian defense and we and the end
that would be it so thank you guys and
see you next time
basically in ten minutes because we're
gonna do another class very soon so stay
tuned and see you then
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you